hello Conan and soda hey question I'm
good how are you we're good what's your
name Ashley hey Ashley hello so I just
wanted to know hypothetically if you
could be a podcast host in any other
historical period which one would you
choose and why for both oh I know mine
Yes mine would be like 1920s because I I
love the way people spoke about them
they spoke really quickly and their
voice was up here and then so I just
said right here when my voice naturally
is and you know there's just a lot of
like there's a big skinny uh Hey there
you know Mr Mrs America and all the
ships at Sea big new skinny just came
through off the Great Lakes it seems
like a Mr Mrs Huron are having a little
bit of a Paddy finger situation you know
it's all [ __ ] it doesn't really
matter people would just go on and on
and on I was at the store club and I saw
Joe DiMaggio walk through he had he had
biggest beef pie I've ever seen but
anyway that's hard to lose for the day
and then I would leave there and go to
the Stork Club and yeah and be excited
because that guy from the radio is here
yeah and you'd wear the Fedora I wear a
fedora and I said like hey you got me a
beef pie see
you're still talking like that even when
you're not oh yeah I would always have
the microphone with me
um so yeah that would be that would be
my era oh I think this is my era I don't
know every time I think about older eras
I just think of you know girls getting
their asses slapped a lot I don't know
that's not Am I Wrong Am I Wrong no like
if it the 60s that's a cool era but oh
yeah no it's not for ladies in the
workplace so this is this I'll stay here
you like this this era this era is cool
wait do you think when you were working
in the 90s uh well you weren't working
in the 90s 2000s when were you working
at Taco Bell
um it was Burger King and it was uh in
the late 90s okay I got respect at
Burger King but also I was running the
drive-through so they you have to get
respect at the drive through
the orders out in 30 seconds or less so
right it's a lot of pressure right it's
very important it's like being a surgeon
yes it's just like being a surgeon
working the drive-through section of the
Burger King the Burger King yeah